[موسيقى]
عن الكتيبه تحمل مفاجات في جعبتها
خارج الحسابات السياسيه والامنيه
انتفضت الضفه الغربيه
من جنين الى نابلس الى مدن اخرى
تمددت شراره المقاومه
من فرض واقع لضفه اخرى
قد تبددت
صافرات الانذار تدوي في مخيم جنين مشهد
يتكرر مع كل اشتباه بتسلل قوات خاصه
اسرائيليه الى داخل المخيم
عناصر المقاومه ينتشرون في كل مكان
العين هنا على كتيبه جنين الاسم الابرز
بين التشكيلات المسلحه للمقاومه
[موسيقى]
في هذا التحقيق يدخل ما خفي اعظم الى
كواليس كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
الذراع العسكريه لحركه الجهاد الاسلاميه
التي تتم في ظروف اهميه المعقده
في هذه اللقطات الحصريه يظهر عناصر من
كتيبه جنين اثناء تدريبات الرمايه
المختلفه
لقطات حديثه تعكس التطور الذي مرت به
الكتف بعد ان بدات بافراد معدودين وان
كانت محدوده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التي قادها القائد في سرايا القدس جميل
العموري مع نهايه معركه سيف القدس في مايو
ايار عام 2021 كانت اذانا واعلانا اوليا
لتشكيل مابات يعرف اليوم بكتيبه جينيه
في هذه الانتفاضه المبارك فلسطين
تمكنا في هذا التحقيق من مقابله احد قاده
ومؤسسي الكتيبه الذين رافقوا جميل العموري
في مسيره التاسيس
جميل العموري اول يعني اول المؤسسين
المتردين كان وحده موجود في الشارع
كلهم بالله عليكم اطلقوا النار يعني كان
وحيد وحيد بمعنى الكلمه
عليه عده شبان بالمخيم يعني اصبح عددهم لا
يتجاوز عدد الاصاب في اليد الواحده فبداوا
باستهداف تجمعات لجنود الاحتلال ونقاط
التماس في مناطق القريبه من مدينه جنين
عند معركه سيف القدس كان يعني عدد الشباب
تقريبا الشباب
القدس لحد اليوم ما انتهتش
لم تتاخر اسرائيل باستهداف العموري فجر
العاشر من حزيران يونيو عام 2021
اغتاله قوه الخاصه اسرائيليه جميله
العموري داخل جنين الى جانب اثنين من جهاز
الاستخبارات العسكريه الفلسطينيه
بالشباب
الشبان له اثرت كثير على الشباب بالضفه
الغربيه بشكل عام فمن هون بلشت القصه
وبلشت الحكايه زي ما بيقولوها وبلشت يعني
الشباب واحد
الجهاد الاسلامي هو من تحكم بالايقاع منذ
سنوات هناك وفي مركز المخيم بدا تظهر
ملامح ما يشبه كتيبه وهذه ليست كتيبه
المنضويين تحت مجموعات صغيره لهذا على
اسرائيل ان تحارب هذه الحركه
فمن يحاول قتلك اسبقه واقتله من يعيش على
الدم لا يمكن تركه في المحيط يتحرك بحريه
قامت اسرائيل باستهداف منهج لقيادات
الجهاد الاسلامي في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع
غزه وصلت ذروه التصعيد مع حرب جنتها
اسرائيل على اسرائيل غزه في اغسطس عام
2022 واستمر ثلاثه ايام كان هدفها الاول
ضرب قياده الجهاد الاسلامي في الداخل
والخارج استهداف ما زال مستمرا وبوسائل
مختلفه
خلال هذا التحقيق تكشف سرايا القدس لما
خفي اعظم عن افشالها مخططا لاختراق صفوفها
من قبل المخابرات الاسرائيليه
وتوجيهها لضربه امنيه المضاده
[موسيقى]
الترتيبات معقده وصلت للقاء احد ابرز واهم
المطلوبين لاسرائيل القائد العسكري الاول
في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي والرجل النادر في
ظهوره اعلاميه والذي تتهمه اسرائيل
باداره وقياده عمليات سرايا القدس في
الدقه الغربيه
اكرم العجوري الشخصيه التي سعت اسرائيل
خلفها طويلا يقود الرجل سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكريه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
في هذه الصور الحصريه يظهر العجوري مع عدد
من قاده السرايا الذين اغتالتهم اسرائيل
وابرزهم بهاء ابو العطا وتيسير الجعبري
وخالد منصور اليوم عيون اسرائيل تلاحق
العجوري الذي تحمله المسؤوليه عن تطور
كتيبه جنين وتمددها
في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني عام 2019 تعرض
العجوري لمحاوله اغتيال اسرائيليه فاشله
استهدفته في العاصمه السوريه دمشق
سيد اكرم العجوري انت على راس المطلوبين
لاسرائيل في الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي وقد نجته من عمليه اغتيال استشهد
فيها احد ابنائك هل هذه العمليات
بالاستهداف ما زالت مستمره شوف العدو اصلا
بطبيعته هيك وعده وعدو غادر وعدو يعني
نحن نتوقع منه خلافه ذلك واحنا عندنا
اخترنا هذا الطريق
افضل منا في الاداء وافضل منه في التاثير
باختياله
بالنسبه همم حسابات كثيره
هو العضو اكيد حصل على معلومات ساعدته
وانا اعتقد كمان في هناك طرف اخر ساعدوا
مساعده كانت مهمه جدا
ولن اذكر هذا الطرف الاخر جهاز امن تابع
دوله
بس هذا الرساله
نحن نعلم جيدا من وراها لكن
كل كل حدث حديثه وكانت هذه الدخول هذا
الطرف كان حاسما في تحديد مكانكم الوصول
اليكم
في اللحظات الاخيره بالنسبه
محاوله اغتيال بساعات هو اكيد بيشخص
المكان
عبر الاتصالات لكن هو كان بهميه يحدد
الساعه والوقت
بدقه الذي يكون في متواجد في المنزل يعني
كان هذا مهم جدا لدي انه انا موجود اكون
من الشام هذا في سوريا يعني سوريا الشقيقه
دائما سوريا وفي
بيتي لانه انا كنت اتنقل كثير
في البيت
وبالفعل همم تم تحديد ذلك اسرائيليا انت
المتهم كقائد عسكري اول لسرايا القدس
باداره كتيبه جنين وتوجيهها كتيبه جنين
القدس
طبيعي لتاريخ جديد
الان بعد 20 سنه
يظهر له
بابطاله شجاعه اهله تماسكهم سيجامهم
الاجتماعي كل بيت في جنين في جنين يكاد ان
اقول كل بيت في شهيد واسير
ما يظهر في جنين هذا
المستعاره هو تاريخ البطولات تتراكم
مرت كتيبه جنين بمراحل معقده من التطوير
في هذه اللقطات الحصريه يظهر عناصر من
الكتيبه اثناء اعدادهم لعبوات الناسفه
وقنابل محليه باساليب بدائيه استعدادا لصد
اي اجتياح اسرائيلي محتمل للمخيم
كما يظهر هنا عناصر من كتيبه جنين يقومون
بتجارب ناجحه لعمليه تفجير لعبوات تم
تصنيعها حديثا
[موسيقى]
لاحقا تم استخدامه احدى هذه العبوه في
تفجير استهدف رتلا عسكريا اسرائيليا خلال
العمليه التي قام بها جيش الاحتلال غرب
جنين قبل ايام من بث هذا التحقيق
هذه الوحده التي تقوم برصد تحركات العدو
من مخصوم الجرم او مخصوم سالم او اي طريقه
يدخلون الينا منها كل الطرق تحت وحده
الرصد والمتابعه او على النقاط الحوادث
والوحده الثانيه وحده المتفجرات التي تكون
بتصنيع العبوات المحليه الصنع لمقارعه هذا
العدو والوحده الثالثه وحده المواجهه
والاشباب
[موسيقى]
هل بنيت كتيبه جنين هي بنيه صلبه تنظيميا
عسكريا بالنظر الى ما تعرضت له من عمليات
اغتيال واستهداف مستمر وان الظروف ايضا في
الضفه الغربيه ليست ظروف مثلا في غزه حتما
الكتيبه الان في طور بناء وتصاعد
وهذا وهذا البناء لا يتوقف على الكتيبه
كمال الكتيبه تحتاج الى روافد هذه تحتاج
الى متعدده نحن الان بفضل الله لدينا
كتائب في نابلس في جبع في طوباس في طولكرم
عدد افراد الكتيبه يعني هل الاعداء تتطور
يعني نتحدث عن عشرات عن مئات هو الاعداد
انت تستطيع ان تقول لاعداد ليست ليست
تعداد محدوده اعداد كبيره يعني كنا اعداد
بالعشرات نعم العشرات مجهزه
ولا على قدر عالم من ال اول شيء التجهيز
كامل
بالسلاح
الخبره اصبح لديه خبره وحاضنه هؤلاء قد
يصل الى المئه لكن الكتله الصلبه للكتيبه
هي اعداد يعني
قريبه من المائه او اكثر قليل
من الشباب
الكتيبه واكبر دليل على ذلك انك تجد قطعه
سلاح للشهيد يحملها بعده شخص اخر لا يوجد
لدينا قطعه سلاح للشهيد بقيات بدون رجل
يحملها
عملي
ورطه
على جنوب اسرائيل
للمره الاولى
منذ اعلاني بيانها الاول وحتى اليوم اتبعت
كتيبه جنين اسلوب الاشتباك المباشر
والقريب من القوات الاسرائيليه
وقامت بعدد من عمليه الصد للتوغل
الاسرائيلي
ومهاجمه حاجز الجلمه العسكري في اكثر من
مناسبه ما شكل لمنطقه ظلت هادئه للسنوات
كان من اهم عمليات الكتيبه عمليه حومش
والتي هدفت الى اسر جنود اسرائيليين عمليه
وصفتها اسرائيل بالتغير الخطير وبالفشل
الامني لاجئتها
عمليه خطيره جدا ومهمه جدا كالعامليه يقصد
قادتها اللي هو محمود جرادات
وعمر وغيث عدد من ابناء الجهاد كالهدف
منها قتل مؤثر هم قتلوا
يعني عاملين حسابهم جدا للاسر
قضيه الاسرار قضيه من اهم قضايا نحن
نهتم بها نعتبره قضيه بالنسبه
نجحت العمليه في التنفيذ قتل مستوطن اااه
عقامه وعدد اصيبه بالسياره كان متوقع
السياره تتوقف
بسبب اطلاق النار لكن السائق باين انه
يصيب يعني
واستمر
بالسياره فابتعد عن المكان والسحب الاخوه
استاذ منير ما تشهده الضفه الغربيه
استراتيجيا ما هي تاثيراته ما يحدث في
الضفه الغربيه شيء لم يسبق له مثيل وهو
فريد من نوعه يعني الان اذا كنت تتحدث
وتعيد
الانتفاضات الاولى والثانيه مظاهر
تفاجئ انه انت تواجه شيء ما سبق انه حدث
في الضفه الغربيه خصوصا انه الطفل الغربيه
انشغل عليها كثير انها تنام وما تكون في
مستوى المقاومه واللي عم بتصير الان في
الضفه الغربيه لذلك انا اعتقد من ناحيه
استراتيجيه ابعاده كثيره ومهمه جدا انه
نضج الظروف
في موازين القوه من هذا الجانب من هذا
الجانب تسمح
لافراد انه يقدمه
انجاز ضد العدو وفعلا بكل المعارك اللي
صارت العدو كان خسران فيها وشهداء ربحانين
فيها
الفصائل يعني
في وحده يعني بالميدان فش فرق بين هذا من
جهاد اسلامي هذا من كتائب القسام
في الميدان كلنا اخوه يعني سلاح احنا لمده
يتوجه يتوجه بالنهايه لعدو واحد فمن فركش
فعلشان هيك بتساعد يعني انت بتلاقي بهذا
الشارع من بتلاقي من كل الفصائل الموجوده
فيه
فش عندنا تقسيم بالميدان بين هاي الوحده
وهاي بين هذه الفصيله وهذا الفصيل خلص من
الميدان في وحده في وحده وطنيه بالنهايه
نحنا اولاد شعب واحد فمن قاتل فك شخص واحد
[موسيقى]
في مخيم جنين
الاهميه
مثلا لانه نتنياهو وفريقه الحكومي
والسياسي تواعد بواد ما يجري في الضفه من
هذه العمليات العسكريه وهذه النشاطات
العسكريه
اخي ثاني لكن اياهم مشروع هو مشروع تطبيقي
اولوياته في التطبيع التطبيع المنطقه الان
هو يعتقد هو علام تماما انه جيشه غير قادر
على خوض معارك مفتوحه في المنطقه وغير
قادر عاجز فبالتالي يعوض ذلك في السياسه
التطبيعه وهذا اولويه
وهو يعتبر انه هو يعني فتح هذا المجال وهو
لدور اساسي عودت نتنياهو نتنياهو كل نفس
النسخه يعني لا جديدنا
ليس افضل ليس الذي كان قبل افضل منه وما
سياتي بعده افضل منه نسخه واحده نتعامل
معهم احنا بجديه ما هو المطلوب منا نقوم
به
وهب لنا من ياتي
لديهم مشروعات لديهم خطط لديهم مع همم من
يعاونهم ونحن نفعل ما هو ما نستطيع ان
نفعله باختصار فبالتالي ليس لدينا يعني
قلق من همم
وهو يعرف انه احنا نعرفه اساسا
مشاهد المقاومه وتشكيلتها سرعان من انتشرت
في المدن الاخرى للضفه الغربيه
ابرزها مدينه نابلس حيث عرين الاسود
في التاسع من ديسمبر كانون الاول عام 2022
ظهر مسلحو العرين في عرض عسكري كان بمثابه
تحدي بعد سلسله الاستهداف والملاحقه
الامنيه لهم
[موسيقى]
في هذا التحقيق حصلنا على فرصه للقاء
قيادات وعناصر من عرين الاسود الذين
اتبعوا مؤخرا السريه الشديده في تحركاتهم
وظهورهم
برز اسم العرين بعد عده عمليات هجوميه
المبارغه في عمليه الهجوم هذه مثلا
استهدفت قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه قرب مستوطنه
شاب شمر في نابلس في الحادي عشر من اكتوبر
تشرين الاول عام 2022
تبنتها عرين الاسود قتل فيها جندي
اسرائيلي وان سحب المهاجمان في السياره
الى موقعهما بسلام
رغم مروري اكثر من شهرين على وقعها ما
زالت اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه تلاحق منفذي
العمليه حيث فشلت اكثر من مره بالوصول
اليهما حتى تاريخ بث هذا التحقيق
[موسيقى]
تمكنا من مقابل عمليه شاف شمر حيث يتحدث
عن تفاصيلها لاول مره
مستوطن العربي
خططنا كيف انه بدنا ننزل كيف بدنا نعمل
العمليه ونرجع بكل هدوء وسلام وركزنا في
حالنا صح ومركزنا في حالنا كيف الامور ميه
الميه تكون
قلنا يا الله توكلنا على رب العالمين
صلينا كل واحد اللي بده ينزل صلينا وكان
لله عز
وجلنا الطريق والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني
حتى البرج القناص تبع البرج واطلقش طلقه
واحده من كثر الخوف اللي قدام عيني على
الاحتلال وصلنا عادي طبيعي شفت دوريه
الجيش
دخلنا شارع اسرائيل تبعهم 17 بسام السياره
رجعنا عليهم
قدامهم بالسياره والمقاتل معنا صاحب سلاحه
طخ عليهم مخزن كامل
الحمد لله رب العالمين
تظهر هذه اللقطات بدايه خروج عناصر العرين
في شوارع البلده القديمه في نابلس قبل ان
يبرز اسم عرين الاسود اعلاميا بعد استشهاد
ثلاثه من مقاومين نابلس في عمليه اغتيال
اسرائيليه في الثامن من شباط فبراير عام
[موسيقى]
هذه الغرفه داخل بيت الشهيد محمد العزيز
مؤسس العرين شهدت بدايات التشكيل للمجموعه
[موسيقى]
في هذا التحقيق قابلنا الرجل الذي يقود
مجموعه عرين الاسود اليوم
شهداء نابلس اخبار نابلس محمد الدخيل عمر
رائد
مبروك الشيشاني واشرف البصمه رحمه الله
عليهم
من هون بدات العرين فكرتها
وتقومي حالها وتعدي بحالها مواجهه هذا
الكيان الصهيوني
الى زمان باذن الله
نحن كلنا كنا اصحاب اولاد بلده واحده
نعرف بعض من قبل يعني انه نكون عرين او
تكون فكره العرين
ويعني اللي بتعاهدوا العرين انه لما يفوت
على عرين الاسود
لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله ما يتلقى
من اي حزب اي تعليمات
[موسيقى]
طلع من من الشعب من بلده القديمه
رحمه الله عليه
وسلم
قوه اصغر من الجماعات التي تحدثنا عنها في
جنين الفريق الكبير ان هذا الامر يدل على
انتشار الموجه الحاليه من الارهاب
والتسعيدي من جنين جنوبا الى مركز شمال
الضفه الغربيه
بمقارنه حجم المدينه واهميتها
ابراهيم ما تخيل كل يوم
بدانا نرى نوعا من التنظيم اكثر من
مشاهدناه مقارنه بجنين
التوجه بعمليات النحو الغرب لداخل اسرائيل
واطلاق النار باتجاه الشوارع الرئيسيه
والمستوطنين والجنود والمواقع العسكريه
وعلى اي شيء يتحرك انهم يدخلون بهذا عاملا
جديدا بصوره بارزه الا وهو الوعد فهذه
المجموعه تستغل معرفتها بالشبكات
الاجتماعيه
دخلونا ان ادخل على الطريق اول
حضاره الانتفاضه الثانيه
افوت البلده القديمه انا كنت بدار سيدي
هون موجودين افوت اطلع على الجيش كيف بفوت
كيف بقتل بالناس يعني كيف بيعمل عملياته
بالناس كيف بهدف بيوتهم فوق رؤوسهم
الذي جرى هل هو امتداد طبيعي لما يجري في
حاله الضفه الغربيه هل هناك تنسيق مباشر
بين هذه الكتائب في تعاود كبير بين كثير
الاخ الشهيد القائد الشهيد ابراهيم
النابلسي
اعتقد نموذج وحده العريق الاسود كنموذج
كان ناجح هذا السبب احنا ليس لها برنامج
احتواء ما فيها برامج مطلقا في تفكير حتى
المقاتلين كلهم سواسيه القسام
والمقاومه هذا الاعتبارات يجب ان تخرج من
حساباتنا
اقعدي عمليات المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه
شنت اسرائيل حمله من الاغتيالات المنهجه
طالت قيادات في كل من العرين وكتيبه جنين
عمليات اغتيال تمت بشكل مباشره ونفذتها
قوات خاصه واخرى كانت بتكتيك جديد حيث تم
اغتياله تامر الكيلاني احد قاده العرين
بدراجه المفخخه
[موسيقى]
مقام الشونه
تقوم اسرائيل باستهداف مباشره ضد احد
نشاطات الاسود في نابلس بعد وضع دراجه
ناريه
وفكرتها موجوده وكذلك الماركه المدعوه
عرين الاسود فتخوف من ان الاغتيال ضد اي
من المخربي يزيد من رصيدي او سمعته عرين
الاسود
بمرنا الضرب قاسي ضربه الشهيد القائد
الميداني تامر الكيلاني باغياله عن طريق
دراجه ناريه
اغتيال المؤسس الشهيد محمد العزيزي اغتيال
القائد العام مدير الحواح ولكن العرين
باذن الله باقي ومستمر
وان شاء الله في ميت اب صالح و100 وديع
وميت تامر باذن الله تعالى
[موسيقى]
نشوف عشرات الالاف من الشباب وراء جنازه
مثلا ابراهيم النابلسي شوف المفروض تقول
انه في العشرات والمئات والالاف بدهم
يكملوا الطريق
هذا بدك تقرا ولما تشوف عشرات الالاف من
الجماهير وبالتالي لاول مره عمل مسلح يكون
محتضمه من الشعب بمثل هذه الصوره يعني
تصور حتى وصف انه هاي عمليات فرديه اللي
بتصير اللي سبقته شويه ظاهره جنين وظهرت
نابلس
كيف بنسميها فرديه
والى هذا الاحتضان الشعبي ولذلك انا
التعبير عن اراده شعبيه اكثر منها اراده
فرديه
في ظل فشلها في تطبيق تصاعد وتمدد مجموعات
المقاومه المسلحه في الضفه الغربيه
والاحتضان الشعبي لها عولت اسرائيل على
تنسيقها الامني مع السلطه الفلسطينيه سعيا
لاحتواء المشهد
يوجد عامل اخر الا وهو السلطه الفلسطينيه
التي فقدت السيطره في جنين منذ وقت طويل
وفي حال خسرت السلطه الفلسطينيه نابلس
فستفقد سيطره على اماكن اخرى وبوتيره
سريعه مقارنه مع مشاهدناه حتى اليوم ففي
نابلس لديك اجهزه امنيه تتبع للسلطه امنيا
في شمال الضفه الغربيه في نابلس وجنين
او اربع عمليات في اليوم الواحد وتحولت
لوجع راس حقيقي وفي مقابل الاقتحامات التي
مادرت اليها اسرائيل كانت هناك توجهات من
اسرائيل
لانه في حال لم تقوم بذلك سنقوم نحن في
هذا حناخذ نيبال
نابلس صدامات عنيفه بين اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه ومحتاجين غاضبين على اعتقال
السلطه الفلسطينيه احد النشطاء البارزين
في عرين الاسود مصعب شيه القياديه في
كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس
قد سلم نفسه فانه مصعب قد سحب السلاح على
القوه اخذنا منهم كانهم قوات خاصه
اسرائيليه وعند تاكده انهم ابناء جلدته
ومن ابناء الاجهزه الامنيه لم يقاومهم وقد
كان قاتل المستحقما ولو عقلت النار
ولكنه اعاهد الله وتعاهدنا في كتاب الله
الا يمتد سلاح كان سجل ذلك
مررت السلطه الفلسطينيه اعتقال شتيه بانه
محاوله لحمايته من الاغتيال الاسرائيلي
في هذا التحقيق حصل ما خفي اعظم على هذه
الرساله الحصريه المسربه حديثا بخط مصعب
اشتياق المعتقل لدى اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه منذ قرابه اربعه اشهر عبر فيها
مصعب عن الم فقدانه لرفاق دربه وهو في
السجن
واخرهم الشهيد تامر النشرته من جنين
لكنما المه اكثر بحسب ما قال في رسالته
انه عرف بخبر اغتيال رفيق دربه في عرين
الاسود وديع الحوح بعد اربعه ايام من
الحدث
اشتكى مصعب ظروف اعتقاله قائلا ان القلم
يعجز عن وصف الحال والمعاناه في هذه
المهنه
وما كان فيها من تحقيق من جهه والم فقد
الاحبه من جهه اخرى والمرض الذي استجد على
حاله من جهه ثالثه في ختام رسالته يقول
مصعب اشتيه لا اعلم اذا كانت رسالتي هذه
ستصل اليكم ام انها ستبقى حديثه الجدران
كل الذي اعلمه انني مؤمن بنصر الله وفرجه
قريب امنا ان يبقى مطلبكم بالافراج عني
باسرع وقت ذا اولويه
في الاجهزه الامنيه والافراج عن مصعب
الفوري ويا ريت يعني انهم اعتقال في افراد
واسود العرين نحن الان اريد صداع كلها من
قبل ونقول الان نحن لا نريد صدام مع
اخواتنا في الاجهزه الامنيه نحن فقط ضد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
في ان تم
تطوير اصدامي بين الاجهزه الامنيه
والمحتل لكن معطى جديده برز على الساحه
عروض لتسويه اوضاع المقاومين عبر تسليم
سلاح مقابل الحفاظ على حياتهم
[موسيقى]
الشرطه الفلسطينيه في الحقيقه سمحت
اسرائيل
لسلطه بتولي معالجه الامر فلا يوجد لدينا
رغبه بمشاهده قتال داخلي بين السلطه
الفلسطينيه وهذه الجماعات ضمن هذه العناصر
اللي داخل السلطه
قابلنا في هذا التحقيق محافظه جنين اللواء
اكرم رجوب والذي شغل سابقا محافظ مدينه
نابلس
وسالناه عن حقيقه وجود عروض من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه للمقاومين بتسويه اوضاعهم
معلومات ماذا حصل في نابلس احكي لك بصراحه
ولكن في جنين احنا بنبذي الجهد وفي
الميدان يبذل الجهد من اجل ان يتم الحفاظ
على ارواح كل ابناء شعبنا الفلسطيني بما
فيهم
الذي تطاردهم قوات الاحتلال هسا شكله لونه
والياته بالتاكيد لن اناقشها معك عبر
تقرير مثل هذا التقرير
الاسود الذين قابلناهم في هذا التحقيق عن
تفاصيل العروض التي قدمت اليهم
بتسليم انفسنا على الاجهزه الامنيه هناك
هذا خيار شخصيه لكل شخص يريد ان يسلم نفسه
[موسيقى]
لكن
المسلم نفسه
ااا عرض عليه شراء البعوضه المعتوق يعني
مدال على سياره
دفعت شقه تفريخ في الاجهزه الامنيه
هذه العروضو عليك رد علي سلم نفسه ورد علي
اخذ شقه كامله بدون ماء للسفينه عرض عليهم
انه اقساط انعرض علي اني اخذ شقه كامله
اخذ سياره وهدف اني بس اني اسلم حالي منه
انه امان على حياتي طبعا الحمد لله رب
العالمين قبل ما ادخل هذه الطريق كان وضع
المادي ممتاز جدا ومش محتاج حدا يمد معي
اي شيء
الماده ممتاز
لو بدي لو بدي اتراجع من الاساس بس انا
ماشي اذا شهد في سبيل رب العالمين
الاسود هل تعرض افراد كتيبه جنين التابعه
لسرايا القدس له عروض بتسويات بالقاء
السلاح مقابل حمايتهم من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه
فتح الشهداء
الاسلام
كيف تنظر الى ما يجري في نابلس حاليا من
تسويات
مع افراد علينا الاسود مثلا من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه يعني انا متاكد او شهاده عمل
مخصي
ومرفوض ومستنكر وهذا ضد فتح وضد المقاومه
وبالتالي انا متاكد انها هيفشل يعني اذا
استطع ان يعني يستغل تلاته اربعه يعني يا
اما اوري واما ضغطت عليهم الى اخره لكن
الظاهره مستمره وقويه وراح ضل المستمره
بدليل موقف الشعب انا كمان اللي همم يعني
ملفت نظري في تقدير الموقف هو الموقف
الشعبي طيب هلا بتنزل المظاهر يجي هلا
يستشد واحد جديد في نابلس هتشوف الشوارع
حتى تمتلئ مره ثانيه وحتى يصير في شغل
تمام ولذلك انا براي هذا عمل لازم يفشل
ويفشل المؤسس الامنيه ملتزمه بالمعنى انها
ان تلقت قرارا
على مواجهه الاحتلال ستواجه
ولكن لا هذا امر معقد وليس من السهل ان
اييه بجره يلى من يجي واحد او تحريض على
الفيسبوك يقول لك والله يلا هبو يا ابناء
المؤسس الامنيه هذا كمان في ارواح ابناء
الشعب الفلسطيني وارواح ابناء المؤسسه
الامنيه لن نعرضهم للخطر مشان ارض فلان او
ارض علان او هذا التنظيم او ذاك التنظيم
السلطه
خلاص كفايه يعني هذا العدو مجرب ولا داعي
يعني مجرب وانهم
وصلوا لهذا القناه لكن احيانا ما بعرف انا
حسابات عندهم قد كيف لهم حسابات لا
مرتبطات لكن انا تقديري هذا كله لا يفيد
كثير
ويجب ان يا ابن الجهد كبير في الابتعاد او
حتى يمتنعوا عن اي اعتقال عن اي مضايا
مضايق الاخوان المجاهدين
سواء كان باعتقالات وكان
بمصادرات اسلحه اموال السلطه ان توقف هذا
العمل وفور هذا عمل مش مجدي وسانعكس عليها
سالبه في المستقبل
وعليه فان الطريقه الوحيده التي اراها هو
عدم رؤيه هؤلاء الاشخاص كبشر يعيشون مثلنا
على وجه الارض
لا تعزل اسرائيل ما يجري في الضفه الغربيه
عن غزه والتطورات خارج الحدود كما انها لا
تخفي سعيها الحديث لاستهداف قاده المقاومه
واغتيالهم في اي مكان تطاله ايديها
خلال اللقائنا مع قائد سرايا القدس اكرم
العجوري في لبنان كان لافتا التدابير
الامنيه التي تحيط بالرجل في ظل معلومات
يكشفها العجوري عن تفاصيل محاولات اسرائيل
الاستهدافه
حاول عدو اكثر من محاوله
اعتقدنا فيها
افراد واعتقل ولا اعرف في منهم كانت هنا
في بيروت ام في دمشق كل معظمها كانت في
دمشق بس في احد العملاء لبنان هو كان جاء
من بيروت الى الى دمشق وتم اعتقاله في
عميل اخر من غزه كان سوريا وتم كشفه وتقال
وفي محاولات على تقديري هذه الواحد لا يفص
على كثير محاولات القتل
لا احنا نعرف من حاول ولكن
ربما العدو لا يعرف ان نحن نعرف ولكن ربنا
كتبنا النجاه
امنيه نفذها جهاز امن سرايا القدس
يكشف عن تفاصيلها لاول مره
حيث تمكن الجهاز الامني لسرايا القدس من
زرع عميل مزدوج للعمل مع جهاز الشباك
الاسرائيلي وهو المجلد 106 من قطاع غزه
اشهر من العمل السري والخفي طلب بعدها
ضباط الشباب مقابله المجند 106 داخل
اسرائيل لتكليفه بمهامه حساسه وتدريبه
للقيام بها لاختراق السرايا
وتفاصيل ارسال المجند 106 للداخل المحتل
احتاج اتخاذ قرار ارسال المجند 106
بمقابله ضابط مخابرات العدو
وجها لوجه لجهد كبير ودراسه على مستوى
قياده امن سرايا القدس
نظرا لما يحيط بهذه المهمه من مخاطر
هذه الصور الحصريه توثق لحظات عبور المجند
106 للقاء الضباط الاسرائيليين عند نقطه
الحدوديه تم تحديدها مسبقا من قبل الشباك
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
قبل ما تطلع من بين الدور تتصل فيه بتحكي
مع كلمتين وبنخليك فاتح
لاخر نكته
[موسيقى]
توكل على الله
خليك انا بدي اياك انا بدي ابني يروح سالم
ويروح سالم
بحدود حكى لي خليك معي على الجوال ولا
تسكر الخط
وحكى لي خليك ماشي عدل مشيت حوالي 500 متر
وجهني باتجاه السياره شبه الباص
وطلب مني اطلع فيها
وبعد ما طلعت فيها لقيت فيها كاميرات
مثبته على الجانب طلب مني اشلح ملابسي
كلها
وحكى لي البس البدله العسكريه المعلقه جوه
الباص والبس البوت الموجود
حوالي ربع ساعه
دخلنا منطقه فيها زي كرفان وبعدها لقيت
واحد لابس مدني عرف على نفسه انه هو
الضابط ابو علي وبعد ما تلاقينا بيوم
عرفني على الضابط ادم اللي هو ابو خالد
وبعدها تم تدريبي على عمليه التصوير من
جوال قلاب
وعلى كيف ارسل الاسطوره من غزه
بعد ما ارجع وخليني اشوف صور لمجموعه من
شباب اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
حبيبي انا مبسوط بالسلامه وتكونش قلقان
الله يرضى عليك بكره بنكون على طوباس
عشان تفوت لك حمام في امان الله وبنكون
على اتصال بكرا المغربيه ان شاء الله يلا
الله يحميكم الحمد لله على السلامه
وهو احد عناصرها قد نجح في تصوير الضابط
الاسرائيلي سرا خلال اللقاء الذي جمعه به
في احد مطاعم القدس وكشفه هويته الحقيقيه
عندما عاد المجند 106 الى قطاع غزه بعد
انجازه للمهمه ولقائه المباشر مع ضابط
مخابرات العدو
حقق مجموعه انجازات اهمها كشف هويه ضابط
مخابرات العدو المعروف بادم الملقب بابو
خالد بل وتمكن من تصويره ايضا
وتم كشف نوايا مخابرات العدو خاصه الضابط
ادم تجاه عدد من عناصر وقاده سرايا القدس
المصادفين الذين عرضوا ضابط مخابرات العدو
ادم صورهم على المجند 106
دون اغتيال العدول حتى السرايا القدس
الميدانيه
كما يكشف الجناح العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي
ان المجند 106 كان ضمن شبكه من المجندين
المزدوجين الذين نجحوا في كشف مخططات
الشباك الاسرائيليه التي كانت تستهدف
اختراق المقاومه واغتيال عدد من قادتها
[موسيقى]
هذا غامبول
تقريبا وه
عند السياره انا من ناحيتي ما انتهت
المقيمه لحد ما انت بتجيبني بالظبط البيت
الاخوه في القسام وسلطه الاخوه في حماس
تنسيق عالي في الموضوع كثير تهديد كبير
علينا يعني في تنسيق عالي في هذا الموضوع
تعاون كبير جدا في المعلومات في المتابعه
في العمل على العملاء المزدوجين وهذا
تحتاج الى جهاز يقابل الجهاز يعني هذا عقد
العمليات انك انت تتابع مين الزواج هذا
تحتاج الى يعني مهاره خاصه
الحمد لله
نشعر في تطور كبير وفي توفيق بهذه المسائل
اللي بيقوموا بها لدينا وفي نجاحات حقيقه
يحققها رغم انه لا اله الا الله حتى الان
يوجد بعض
الاخفاقات بتحدث لان انت امام كم هائل من
ال من مع الاسف
ما يقوم به العدس وكان من تجنيد او من جمع
معلومات
التسجيلات الحصريه كشفت عددا من اسرار عمل
المخابرات الاسرائيليه واساليب تجنيدها
لكن الاهم انها كشفت ان المقاومه سجلت
نقاط على الاحتلال في معركه امنيه يعول
عليها كثيرا لاضعاف تمدد المقاومه
والتنسيق بين جبهتها
الذي يعجز اسرائيلي اشياء كثيره جدا
وبالاخص كمان
الضفه اليوم مرتبطه بغزه مرتبطه خارج غزه
المحور المقاومه
شيء كثير
وما يظهر على لسان قاده المقام في بنت
تهديدات من استعداداتهم
ان يعرف ان اي معركه مفتوحه قادمه
ستكون لها ما لها نهايه من لا اقول
ندعى ذلك
[موسيقى]
تتعدد ساحات المواجهه وتتوسع
وتسقط الرهانات الامنيه والمسارات
السياسيه
ليعود خيار المقاومه مجددا
فاردا حضوره وفعلياته امام التطرف
اسرائيلي سياسيا وشعبي غير مسموح
فبرزت الضفه الغربيه
باسماء كتائبها وافعال مقاومها
لتطويه صفحه وتفتح اخرى
وما خفيه
[موسيقى]